[الموسيقى
] تجعلني أشعر بالدوار وكأنني
أتجول كثيرًا ، لقد اضطررت
إلى تقليل تدريباتي واضطررت إلى
ركوب الحافلة على سبيل المثال ، أو
في الصباح لم أستقل الحافلة حقًا ،
فهذا أكثر  لشيء ما بعد الظهر ، ولكن
كان علي أن أستقل الحافلة هذا الصباح ،
فأنا لست سعيدًا بشأن ذلك
الأجنبي
نظرًا لاستمرار ارتفاع درجة حرارة المناخ ،
سنشهد إطالة موسم الحرائق
، وقد ظهر ذلك في العديد من
المناطق حول العالم
وحيث أن هذا يحدث ، فإننا نطيل بشكل أساسي
الفترة الزمنية التي
يمكن أن تشتعل فيها الحرائق ويمكننا التفكير في
هذا على أنه من بعض النواحي شيء
يجب أن نتوقع المزيد منه في
المستقبل فيما يتعلق بهذه الأيام الدخانية
الأجنبية
[موسيقى]
أنت تعلم أنني كنت آمل أن أرى
يومًا جميلًا هنا في سياتل ولكن
لسوء الحظ كان كل الدخان يتصاعد